comprendre la crise aux vivants il faut
comprendre sur quoi se basent son
économie n'ayant pas d'industrie forte
le liban a longtemps compté sur ge et
capitaux étrangers en les attirant via
des placements juteux ou pays et est
même surnommé la suisse du moyen-orient
un système bien huilé qui a fini par se
gripper
car les tensions géopolitiques dans la
région ont fait fuir les investisseurs
résultat les réserves en dollars du pays
ont fondu comme neige au soleil
malgré la limitation des retraits des
transferts de la devise américaine
mise en place en novembre cette rareté
du dollar a fait chuter la valeur de la
livre libanaise sur lequel est indexé en
découle une hausse des prix une
inflation des entreprises qui mettent
peu à peu la clé sous la porte
au liban le chômage atteint gay 37% 48%
des libanais ville sous le seuil de
pauvreté
22 sous celui d'extrême pauvreté des
produits importés comme les médicaments
ou le tabac ont disparu des magasins
d'autres produits de base ont vu leur
prix augmenter parfois jusqu'à 300%
condamnant la majorité des vies d'années
a par exemple renoncer à la viande
prix l'armée qui l'a retiré de ses repas
en novembre ou à voir le prix du kilo de
tomates se multiplier par 4 une
situation si catastrophique qu'elle
pourrait déboucher sur un exode massif
des libanais pour tenter de trouver un
horizon meilleur à l'étranger
[Musique]